THREE O'CLOCK AND SINCE WE ARE
DEALING WITH THE CALIFORNIA%
MILITARY DEPARTMENT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE START RIGHT ON
TIME.
BUT SUDDEN EVEN THOUGH YOU GUYS
ARE RIGHT ON TIME THE MEMBERS
AREN'T AND SO --
I'M SURE THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE COMING IN ND OUT BECAUSE
IT'S A VERY BUSY AFTERNOON.
SO -- I WANT
TO OF THINK THE DEPARTMENT AND
MAJOR GENERAL BEAVERS FOR MAKING
HIMSELF AVAILABLE TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR AN OVERVIEW.
A LOOK BACK AND MAYBE A LOOK
AHEAD AT THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENTS OPERATIONS.
OF FOR THE BENEFITS OF THE NEW --
MEMBER --
I'LL INTRODUCE YOU TO GENERAL
BEAVERS AND THEN YOU MAY BE
AGAIN.
A MAJOR GENERAL MATTHEW BEAVERS
WAS APPOINTED ASSISTANT ADJUTANT
GENERAL IN TWENTY ELEVEN HIS
MILITARY CAREER STRETCHES BACK
AS FAR AS NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
M. BEGAN IN THE ARMOR CORE.
IT INCLUDES DEPLOYMENTS TO A
BOSNIA FOR EACH.
AND TOO HUNGRY TO TRAIN --
FREE IRAQI FORCES IN PREPARATION
FOR OPERATION IRAQI FREEDOM INTO
AFGHANISTAN FOR OPERATION IN
DURING FREEDOM.
MAJOR GENERAL BEAVERS HAS BEEN
AWARDED THE LEGION OF MERIT AND
THE BRONZE STAR AMONG OTHER
RECOGNITIONS --
GENERAL BEAVERS I BELIEVE WE
PLANNED ON STARTING WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW FOLLOWED BY BLOCKS ON
SELECT PROGRAMS.
IN THE DEPARTMENT AND WILL
FOLLOW EACH BLOCK WITH QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS SO [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
ON BEHALF OF THE ADJUTANT
GENERAL IN THE TWENTY THOUSAND
IN AND SOLDIERS AND CIVILIANS OF
FAMILIES THAT MAKE UP THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENTS --
GREAT OPPORTUNITY HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT GIVEN
UPDATE AND TAKE WHATEVER
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE --
I GUESS IT'S PROBABLY IMPORTANT
START OUT JUST BRIEFLY EXPLAIN
WHAT THE MILITARY PART IN HIS
HOUSE ORGANIZED WE HAVE FOUR
MAIN COMPONENTS WITHIN THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA
AIR NATIONAL GUARD.
THE CALIFORNIA ARMY NATIONAL
GUARD OUR YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS TASK FORCE WHICH WILL A
TALK ABOUT A BIT LATER.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE MILITARY
RESERVE AND THAT'S VERY MUCH
LIKE AN AUXILIARY --
MAINLY VOLUNTEERS --
AND THEY PROVIDE A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF VALUE --
OR ORGANIZATION. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WAS EXTRAORDINARILY
BUSY TIME FOR THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT --
WE'VE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
MITIGATING IN RESPONDING TO THE
THE DELETERIOUS EFFECTS THE
CLIMATE CHANGES HAD OUR STATE.
WHO PARTICIPATED IN A MAJOR
FARMERS AND SEES WE WERE CALLED
OUT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN TIMES?
THAT'S A LITTLE OVER ONCE EVERY
THREE DAYS LAST CALENDAR YEAR --
FORTY EIGHT HUNDRED SOLDIERS AND
AIRMEN DEPLOYED ACROSS THE STATE
AND WE ALSO CONTINUE.
TO FIGHT AND WIN OUR NATION'S
WARS IN SUPPORT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S CONTINUE SEE
OPERATIONS ABROAD --
WE'VE DEPLOYED.
TO A LOT OF PLACES LIKE I WANT.
TO WALK THROUGH EACH ONE SIX
IMPORTANT UNDERSTANDS WE
DEPLOYED TO IRAQ TO AFGHANISTAN.
TO JORDAN TO CUTTER TO BAHRAIN
TO KUWAIT TO KUANTN WILL BE
CUBA TO NIGER TO CLOSE OF A IN
UKRAINE ALL IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN SOURCE SOLDIERS ARE
COMMITTED GLOBALLY.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO COMMITTED TO
THE STATE AND THAT'S WHAT
DIFFERENTIATES THE NATIONAL
GUARD FROM.
THE RESERVES OR FROM THE ACTIVE
COMPONENT STATE MISSION TO
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH
WE LIVE AND WORK --
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SOLDIERS DEPLOYED LAST YEAR WE
HAVE THIRTEEN HUNDRED SOLDIERS
DEPLOYED TODAY ACROSS THE GLOBE.
AND WE FULLY EXPECT THE TEMPO
NEXT YEAR THIS YEAR RATHER TO BE
AS AS EXTRAORDINARY AS LAST
YEAR'S WAS --
A COUPLE MORE TO BUT STILL GET
INTO QUESTIONS --
OUR COMPUTER NETWORK DEFENSE
TEAM TEAMS TO BE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR CORE FOR
PARTNERS.
AND WE PERFORMED AT A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF SUBSTANCE
LAST YEAR WE TALK ABOUT THAT IN
SOME DETAIL ARE YOU THINK
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS ARE USED
CHALLENGE ACADEMY STARBASE
CONTINUE TO BE WILDLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED.
A THEY ARE POPULAR --
BEYOND BELIEF.
SO THE LAST THING ON LEAVE YOU
FROM A STATEMENT TODAY'S IS
PLEASE BE REST ASSURED THAT THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT A NATIONAL
GUARD CALIFORNIA.
IS COMPLETELY COMMITTED INVESTED
IN THE ENSURING THE SAFETY OF
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
SO I WOULD YOU WILL BE ASKED TO
GO THROUGH A A CAN YOU TELL
REVIEW OF A SPECIFIC TOPIC OR
START WORK FOR YEARS I THINK
NEMESIS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible] ONE OKAY
[inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
YES TO FOR THE NEW MEMBERS ARE.
BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN IT WAS CLEAR
TO THE ACTION GENERAL MYSELF
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAD A
SIGNIFICANT READING THIS
CHALLENGE BUT IT DEALT WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT AND UNDEREMPLOYMENT
OF OUR SERVICE MEMBERS.
ITS WE DEVELOPED A PROGRAM
CALLED WORKFORCE ESSENTIALLY AN
IN HOUSE HEAD HUNTING FIRM.
IN IT'S NOT IT IT'S NOT A
WEBSITE IT'S NOT A RESUME MIL
IT'S INDIVIDUALIZED.
ATTENTION TO EACH SOLDIER AIRMAN
THAT'S UNEMPLOYED AROUND IN A
UNDER EMPLOYED.
WE WERE ABLE TO WORK WITH YOU
KNOW ALMOST SIX HUNDRED BUSINESS
PARTNERS ACROSS THE STATE.
INDIVIDUALLY TO TO GET OUR
SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN JOBS WHO
WHEN THEY WERE UNEMPLOYED.
WE'VE.
WILDLY EXCEEDED OUR ORIGINAL
GOAL OF REDUCING IN THE
DEPARTMENT BY.
A GUEST 50% IN TWO YEARS AND
UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE DEPARTMENT
NOW RESTED ABOUT 4% --
WHICH IS GREAT --
THE CHALLENGE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
WITH WORKFORCE GOING FORWARD --
AS WE HAVE STRONG ECONOMY WE
HAVE A WORKFORCE SHORTAGES AND
THAT.
THOSE CHALLENGES KIND OF
COMPOUND --
ON HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO DELIVER
VALUE IN WORK FOR WARS WE FOUND
THAT --
DELIVERING VALUE OR FOR IS
REALLY COMES --
TO LOOKING AT FOLKS THAT ARE
UNDEREMPLOYED THOSE SOLDIERS AND
AIRMEN THAT DON'T HAVE JOBS THAT
THAT THE FUNDAMENTALLY SHOULD
HAVE AND ALSO LOOKING AT THOSE
WHO ARE CHRONICALLY UNEMPLOYED.
OFTENTIMES CHRONICALLY
UNEMPLOYED BECAUSE WE'VE
DEPLOYED THEM SO MANY TIMES OVER
YEARS THE COME BACK WITH SOME.
HEALTH CHALLENGES SO WE WERE
VERY HARD TO TRY TO TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT NOBODY GETS LEFT
BEHIND.
AND I I THINK THAT'S THE REALLY
UNIQUE VALUE PROPOSITION OF WORK
FOUR HOURS.
DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS ON WORK
FRAZIER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN --
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE THE --
EXPERTISE THAT CAN BE GAINED.
WITH THEIR SERVICE ON YOU'RE
FREE MECHANIC WHATEVER.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THEIR SERVICES
OVER NAY?
QUITE IN THE WAY.
OPPORTUNISTS WORKFORCE IT SEEMS
LIKE THE WITH THE THE WAY THE
STRUCTURE IS IS.
YOU HAVE TO START ALL OVER AGAIN
WITH THEIR GI BILL FOR
CERTIFICATION OR OR ANY OF THE
OTHER PROCESSES OF THEIR
QUALIFIED HIGHLY QUALIFIED --
FOR JUST SEEMS LIKE IT'S A
REDUNDANT KIND OF WORK.
PROCESS GOES FORWARD IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT WE COULD DO IN
THIS PROCESS THAT COULD ACTUALLY
HELP THIS PROGRAM.
EXPEDITE. EIGHT EXPERT IN THE
FIELD INTO THE WORKFORCE YES.
I THINK --
THE APPROPRIATE PLACE TO GO
THERE IS TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS.
AND OTHERS TO TO ENSURE THAT
MILITARY SKILLS LEARNED AND
EARNED IN THE MILITARY ARE.
TRANSPARENTLY PORTABLE INTO THE
CIVILIAN SECTOR --
MY COLLEAGUE DIFFERENCES BEHIND
ME TODAY'S DONE SOME SIGNIFICANT
WORK ON THAT BUT THEY'RE ALL
THERE IS A LOT OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND I THINK
IT'S FRANKLY LOW HANGING FRUIT I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY WOULD HAVE --
A HUGE CHALLENGE WITH THAT WITH
THAT LEVEL OF TRANSPARENT
PORTABILITY ACROSS THIS THE
MILITARY TO CIVILIAN SECTOR.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IF --
FOR NOT HAVE TO UTILIZE THE G. A
BILL THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THAT. FOR THAT CHILD OF
THAT INDIVIDUAL MOVING FORWARD.
ABSOLUTELY [inaudible]
IT [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA.
THANK YOU CHAIR --
IN GENERAL THINK YOU'VE WITH
PRESENTATIONS ON THIS PARTICULAR
ON THE WAR FOR WARRIORS --
IN THE REPORT TO THE COMMITTEE
AND MENTION SIXTY SIX HUNDRED
PLACEMENTS AT SIX HUNDRED
BUSINESSES HE SPEAK TO THE
QUALITY OF THE THE NATURE OF THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE IDENTIFYING
WITH FOLKS WHO ARE THE PARTNERS
YOU'RE GETTING --
TO TO COLLABORATE HIGHER --
THESE FOLKS.
ABSOLUTELY THAT IT REALLY RUNS
THE GAMUT.
WE PLACE PEOPLE IN TESLA.
AMAZON WE PLEASE PAY ERA PLACE
PEOPLE AT SOUTHWEST AIRLINES WE
ALSO PLACE PEOPLE AT HOME DEPOT
WE ALSO PLACE PEOPLE THAT --
TO DO SECURITY GUARDS WORK SO IT
REALLY RUNS THE GAMUT AND IT
FUNDAMENTALLY DEPENDS ON THE
SKILL SET OF THE OF THE
INDIVIDUAL SOLDIER OR AIRMAN --
SO IT IT'S IT'S EVERYTHING AND
YEAH WE CAN SHOW YOU SOME CAN BE
SOME BACKGROUND OUT ON ON THE
SPECIFICS OF ALL SIX HUNDRED BUT
IT REALLY RUNS THE GAMUT.
SO IT IT'S AT ANY SITUATION IT'S
MATCHED UP IT'S NOT COOKIE
CUTTER IT'S NOW YOU YOU THAT YOU
HAVE A WIDE VARIETY OF FOLKS TO
WORK THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
MAKES OUR PROGRAM UNIQUE.
AND THEN EAT MY CONTACT MY
OFFICE HAS BEEN CAUGHT RICHARD
SEE -- YOU
KNOW INTERESTED IN HELPING FOLKS
TO TRANSITION --
FROM --
THERE -- MOS
NEWS -- TO
TO CIVILIAN SECTOR CAREERS AND
SOME OF THIS HAS TO DO WITH --
CERTIFICATIONS AS THE DEPARTMENT
HAVE ANY YOU KNOW SPONSORED
RECOMMENDED LEGISLATION AND YOU
COME ACROSS THIS DO YOU HAVE --
REQUEST OF THE OF THE OF THE
LEGISLATURE TRYING FACILITATE
THE TRANSITION --
WHEN IT COMES TO SORT OF A
SPECIFIC SKILL SETS RIGHT I I
THINK -- I
THINK WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PARTNER WITH CAL THAT WE'RE
WE'RE FUNDAMENTALLY EMBEDDED IN
THE IN THE THE TRANSITION
PROGRAM TAP --
SO I THINK WE CAN WORK WITH THAT
WITH YOUR WITH YOUR OFFICE CAL
BATS IN YOU --
TO TO EXPLORER EXPLORE WAYS TO
TO TRANSFER FROM TO THE CIVILIAN
SECTOR THINGS ABSOLUTE RIGHT
THING TO DO AND I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY WOULD SAY ANYTHING.
ELSE.
WILL BE FOLLOWING UP WITH A
GREAT PLEASE WOULD LOVE YOUR
HELP AND EXPLAIN Là HOW THIS IS --
TRANSFERABLE --
EXPERTISE PERFECT THANK YOU.
AND CAN YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA ON HOW --
HOW YOU'RE PLACING OTHER --
OF BENEFICIARIES IN QUALIFYING
CATEGORIES OVER VIOLATIONS SULA.
YET IN TOUCH ON IN MY OPENING
REMARKS BUT WE DO WE WE WE HAVE
OPENED UP WORK FOR YEARS NOW TO
EVERY VETERAN.
ACROSS THE STATE EVERY SPOUSE OR
CHILD THE VETERAN OR SERVICE
MEMBER MY ORGANIZATION IS NO
LONGER WHAT IT WAS WHEN IT
STARTED TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
WE'VE EXPANDED DRAMATICALLY --
WE'VE EXPANDED IT TO ENGAGE WITH
FOLKS THAT ARE COMING OFF OF
ACTIVE DUTY CAMP PENDLETON OR
OUT OF THERE FOR SPACES LIKE
TRAVIS RUBIO.
AND TRIED IT TO RAPIDLY
INTEGRATE THEM INTO THE CIVILIAN
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'VE ALSO TAKEN THE
EXTRAORDINARY STEP IN MY MIND OF
GOING OUTSIDE OF THE STATE SO.
IF YOU'RE A SOLDIER FOR BRAG YOU
DON'T SERVICE IN IN IN A STAND
FOR BRAGS AREA YOU CAN GO BACK
HOME A LOT OF THOSE KIDS THAT
SERVE THEIR COME BACK TO
CALIFORNIA.
SUPER WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
INVENTIVE WAYS OF WORKING WITH
CAL THAT TO TO BE ABLE TO GRAB
THOSE KIDS.
WHILE THEY'RE DETERMINING IF
THEY'RE GONNA COME OFF BACK TO
SERVICE WE GRAB THAT IN IN RE
INTEGRATE THEM QUICKLY BACK INTO
THE STATE.
AND KELLY CHAR IN IN EDT AND
OTHERS ARE ARE WORKING WITH US.
TO TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR THOSE.
SERVICE MEMBERS TO APPLY FOR
STATE JOBS OF IT IS A GREAT
PLACE TO COME TO WORK AFTER THE
MILITARY TO COME TO WORK IN
SERVICE OF THE STATE --
AND IT'S VERY ATTRACTIVE TO THAT
DEMOGRAPHICS ARE WORKING VERY
HARD TO TRY TO DO THAT.
AND AND CAL TAP HAS BEEN
EXPANDING PRETTY RAPIDLY SO CAN
HOW IS THAT --
THAT SORT OF PARTNERSHIP GOING
HOW HOW WELL ARE YOU FUNCTIONING
WITH CAT AS AS I MENTIONED%
EARLIER WERE COMPLETELY
INTEGRATED WITH CAL TAP --
WE PARTICIPATE IN IN IT MOST IF
NOT ALL OF OF THEIR PROGRAMS ON
THE VARIOUS --
POSTS CAMPS AND STATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND AND JUST ONE OTHER --
QUESTION THERE IS THERE ARE
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
THE SAME GOALS OF OF EMPLOYING
VETERANS HAVE YOUR A AND METRICS
LOOK COMPARED TO SOME OF THE
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS.
FOR THE THE COST PER PLACE
BEFORE WORKFORCE IS GONE UP
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AND
THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY A FUNCTION
OF IN TWO THOUSAND LEVEL A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE EMPLOYED IF YOU
REMEMBER AND WE WERE ABLE TO TO
GRAB A LOT OF LOW HANGING FRUIT
IF YOU WILL.
NOW IT THE DEPARTMENT AND NOT
SURE WHAT THE THE CURRENT
EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS ARE ACROSS
THE STATE.
MOST FOLKS THAT THAT WANT A JOB
HAVE -- ONE
AND IT BECOMES A FUNCTION LIKE I
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE OF TRYING TO
GRAB THE CIVIC CENTER UNDER
EMPLOYED.
IN THE MORE IMPORTANTLY.
GRABBING THE SPOKES THAT ARE
CHRONICALLY UNEMPLOYED TRYING TO
GET THEM IN A POSITION TO WHERE
THEY CAN HAVE A MEANINGFUL
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
SO WHAT IS RIGHT NOW THE TO THE
COST REPLACE THE TODAY IS ABOUT
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
PLACEMENT.
AND THAT MIGHT SOUND A LOT LIKE
A LOT BUT IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY NOT
THE THE PRIVATE SECTOR COST PER
PLACEMENT TODAY IS ABOUT FORTY
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND THE NEXT BEST COMPETING
FEDERAL PROGRAM LIKE OURS THE
COST REPLACEMENT IS NEXT ALMOST
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO WE STILL ARE BARGAIN.
OKAY AND I'VE ACTUALLY ONE OTHER
THING IN THE I REPEAT FUTURE
NORTH.
WE I OFTEN HAVE PEOPLE COME THAT
EMPLOYERS COMING INTO THE OFFICE
AND TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY WOULD
LIKE TO HIRE MORE VETS.
SO WE'LL LOOK AT HOW DO THEY GET
IN TOUCH WITH YOU HOW WE YOU
KNOW.
WHAT IS THE PROCESS FOR HIGH --
PUTTING ADDITIONAL EMPLOYERS ON
REALLY VERY SIMPLE JUST BE REACH
OUT TO OUR WORK FORCE TEAM ABOUT
TWELVE FOLKS RIGHT NOW.
A RUN BY AN EXTREMELY CAPABLE --
MAJOR SHANNON TERRY AND THAT
THEY BE MORE THAN HAPPY --
TO TO GET THEM LINKED TOGETHER
WITH OUR TEAM AND GET THEM ON
THE LIST OF BUSINESS PARTNERS.
WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING BY THIS
AFTERNOON YOU MENTIONED THAT OUR
GOVERNMENT RULES CAN BE A AT A
GOOD STEP FOR FOR PEOPLE COMING
OUT OF THE MILITARY WHAT
SPECIFIC THINGS CAN WE DO. TO
HELP BY TO HELP YOU MAKE THOSE
MORE POSSIBLE YEAH.
I THINK A LOT'S BEEN DONE
ALREADY COMING AT THE STATE HAS
DONE SOME EXTRAORDINARY WORK IN
ENSURING THAT WE AT THE VETERANS
PREFERENCE POINTS STILL APPLY
AND AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
USUALLY IMPORTANT.
I SEE NO SIGNIFICANT --
STUMBLING BLOCKS A ROAD BLOCKS
TO TO EXECUTING THAT.
THE TASK AS I MENTIONED EARLIER.
EVERYBODY'S VERY VERY SUPPORT
FOLKS EDT THINGS A GREAT IDEA
AND THEY HAVE --
THEY HAVE A RELATIVELY ROBUST
WELL SO I THINK.
WE'RE WE'RE PRETTY WELL LOCK
STEPPED OKAY SET FEELS LIKE
YOU'RE ON TRACK AND I THINK
SEVEN OBJECTIVE GREAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
THE GENERAL IN YOUR OPINION A
AND VETERANS PURPOSE POINTS OF A
LINE I KNOW THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF ASKED A LOT ABOUT SIR
CERTIFICATIONS AND AND ALL OF
THAT I KNOW --
FOR FROM THE MILITARY STANDPOINT
YOU GUYS AREN'T USED TO THE
TRADITION OF OVERSTEPPING YOUR
OPINIONS --
BUT WOULD IT BE SAFE TO SAY THAT
INCREASING VETERANS PROP FROM
POINTS WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP A LOT OF
THESE --
VETERANS GET THE PLACEMENTS
COMING BACK.
AND AS WELL AS LOOKING AT DIRECT
SEARCH [inaudible]
SHOULD [inaudible]
CERTIFICATION --
FOR SOME OF THESE THINGS --
WITH DIFFERENT LIKE PILOT
LICENSES SIGNED OUT WITH --
TRANSPORTATION CORPS YOU STILL
GOT TO GO OUT AND GET EVEN
THOUGH YOU DROVE EIGHTEEN
WHEELERS YUKON THAT'LL AS AS I
WELL NOW --
SO MAKING YOU.
TOUCH BASE A LITTLE BIT ON THAT.
YEAH I I I I THINK I'M IN A
UNIQUE POSITION TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE INCREASE VETERANS PREFERENCE
POINTS AND I THINK I GET IN
TROUBLE FOR THAT --
AND WE NEED TO DO MORE WORK WITH
WITH CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND OTHERS
IN THAT SPACE TO TO MAKE THOSE
THINGS TRANSPARENTLY PORTABLE
MAKE THOSE CERTIFICATIONS THAT
YOU CAN THE MILITARY.
DOUBLE ACROSS THE THE MILITARY
TO PRIVATE SECTOR DIVIDE AND IF
THERE'S FRANKLY KNOW REASON WHY
THAT SHOULD BE THE CASE IF YOU
CAN DRIVE A AN EIGHTEEN WHEELER.
INTO IN FALLUJAH YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DRIVE AN EIGHTEEN
WHEELER DOWN I FIVE FRANKLY
SOMETIMES I FIVE LOOKS LIKE
POLLUTION BUT BUT YOU GET MY
POINT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY THANKS.
SOUNDS LIKE A GREAT
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE BILL
MISTER CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT AND HOW ABOUT THE
STATE OF ARMORIES OKAY YEAH THE
STATE ARMORIES --
SAID THE STATE OWNS NINETY SEVEN
ARMORIES IN CALIFORNIA --
THE CHALLENGING ASPECT OF THAT
IS THERE ARE ON AVERAGE ABOUT
SEVENTY YEARS OLD --
AND WITHOUT THE STATE'S SUPPORT
AND FUNDING CONTRIBUTIONS --
WE COULD NOT --
SUSTAINABLE ARMORY RENOVATION
PROGRAM FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
STATE ARMORIES NONEXISTENT.
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR FEDERAL
ARMIES THE STATE IS ALSO ALMOST
NONEXISTENT --
IT IS ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING THINGS THAT WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT IS THE ABSOLUTE LACK
OF FEDERAL MILITARY CONSTRUCTION
FUNDING COMING IN THE STATE --
SO WE RELY HEAVILY ON THE STATE
TO MAINTAIN OUR REASONING
CONDITION THAT'S ACCEPTABLE TO
THE SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN THAT
WORK AND LIVE IN THEM --
BUT I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE SUSTAINABLE ARMORY
RENOVATION FOR OR SUSTAINABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM IN
GENERAL --
REALLY HAS FOUR PRIMARY PILLARS.
FIRST IS DIVESTITURE WE'VE BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL OVER LAST YEAR'S
I'VE DONE IT DIVESTING OBSOLETE
ARMORIES ARE RESET SIMPLY ARE
BEYOND ECONOMICAL REPAIR.
AND IN THAT CREATES AND
GENERATES CASH FOR US THAT WE
PUT INTO THE ARMORY FUN WHICH WE
IN TURN.
CAN BUILD YOUR WRISTS WITH SO
IT'S IT'S A GOOD IT REDUCES
DRAMATICALLY OUR BACKLOG REPAIR
AND MAINTENANCE.
SO WE'RE TAKING THOSE THOSE
PROPERTIES THAT WOULD BE SUPER
EXPENSIVE TO RENOVATE WERE TAKEN
WOULD DRAMATICALLY REDUCES COSTS --
THE STATE'S ALSO DONE A VERY
VERY GOOD JOB PAYING DOWN --
OUR BACKLOG REPAIR AND
MAINTENANCE AND I THINK TO THE
TUNE OF TWENTY SIX MILLION OR SO
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND
THIS IS A HUGELY IMPORTANT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT AS WE CONTINUE TO
RENOVATE APPROXIMATELY THREE
ARMORIES PER YEAR.
AND THAT'S NEW ROOFS ADA
COMPLIANCE APPROPRIATE BATHROOMS
ALL THOSE THINGS WE HAVE TO DO
TO ENSURE THAT THE SOLDIERS
AIRMEN THAT THAT WORK FOR US
HAVE THE HAVE THE RIGHT AN
APPROPRIATE PLACE TO WORK AND
LIVE.
IN THE LAST THING REALLY THOSE
FOUR PILLARS IS --
OUR OUR PURCHASE OF OF NEW
FACILITIES AND AND WE HAVE TO
ONGOING RIGHT NOW WE EXPECT
BREAK GROUND ON A NEW READINESS
FACILITY THAT ARE THE JOINT
FORCES TRAINING BASE LOS
ELEMENTOS.
IN THE SPRING.
AND WE'RE CURRENTLY BUILDING A
NEW STATE FUNDED HEADQUARTERS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THAT'S ABOUT IT --
NEXT TO MAKE THEIR AIRFIELD SO
NEW CONSTRUCTION DIVESTITURE.
BUYING DOWN ARE A ARE OUR A OR
BACKLOG REPAIR AND MAINTENANCE
AS WELL AS SUSTAINING THE
ARMORIES THAT WE HAVE A REALLY
THE FOUR PILLARS.
OF OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN I
IN MY OPINION VERY VERY
SUCCESSFUL --
BEEN VERY FRUGAL WITH HOW WE DO
IT -- BE WE
HAVE A CHALLENGE IN THE
DEPARTMENT WHERE WE HAVE TO
FUNDAMENTALLY LOOKING TO THE
FUTURE AND SAY WHERE WHERE CAN
WE RECRUIT IN FIVE YEARS TEN
YEARS FIFTEEN YEARS WHAT IS A
DEMOGRAPHIC LOOK LIKE WE'RE THE
SKILL SETS THAT WE NEED.
AND WE NEED TO PLACE THESE
FACILITIES IN SUCH A WAY THAT WE
DON'T OBSOLETE.
WHEN THEY'RE BUILT A BUILDING IN
THE TURN AROUND TEN YEARS LATER
AND WE DON'T NEED BECAUSE WE
MADE A MISTAKE ON WHERE WE PUT
IT -- SO
AND I THINK WE'VE MADE THE RIGHT
CALLS -- SO.
FOR DON'T TELL TO QUESTIONS.
DO WE HAVE ANY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
THANK YOU MEASURE THE SO THE
DIVESTITURE APPROACH THAT'S
BASED ON THE CONDITION OF THE
PROPERTY OR THE STRATEGIC NATURE
OF THE PROPER HEALTH BOTH SO IT
IT'S IT'S THE LOCATION.
IT'S THE ABILITY TO REPAIR IT IN
SUCH A WAY THAT WOULD BE
INHABITABLE --
FRANKLY SOME OF THE ARMORIES
THAT WE'VE HAD IN YEARS PAST OF
BLIGHTED THE NEIGHBORHOODS IN
WHICH THEY WERE AND AND WE WE
TRY TO DIVEST OF THOSE WE ALSO
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE.
WE'RE LOOKING INTO THE FUTURE
WHERE WHERE WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO RECRUIT IN FIVE TEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY YEARS.
AND WE HAVE TO TO PLACE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THOSE
LOCATIONS BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY WERE FUNDAMENTALLY A
COMMUNITY BASED FORCE.
SO WE HAVE TO BE IN THE RIGHT
COMMUNITIES.
I'M SORRY SO SORRY AT A DISTANCE
OF FOLLOW UP ON THAT --
ARE.
ARE ALL THE FUNDS FOR THE
REFURBISHMENT OF THESE OF
FACILITIES THAT YOU'RE RETAINING
IS ALL THROUGH --
LAND CELLS OR IS THAT SOME OF
THAT FROM THE BUDGET.
UP SOME OF THIS FROM THE BUDGET
ALSO SIMMONS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO ON SO YOU WORKING
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT'S
ABOUT THE MATCH.
SUCH YES SO LET ME LET ME BE
CLEAR SO ON MANY PROJECTS WE GET
AT FIFTY FIFTY MATCH SO.
HALF THE MONEY COMES THE STATE
HALF CONSIST FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IN MY OPENING COMMENTS ON THIS
WHEN I TALKED ABOUT FEDERAL
MILITARY CONSTRUCTION DOLLARS
THAT'S THAT'S MONEY SOLELY
FUNDED BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WITH THE PROJECTS FULLY FUNDED
BY THE FEDS.
THAT DOESN'T EXIST BUT THERE'S
RIGHT ACTION FUNDS ABSOLUTELY --
SO AND THAT'S A GREAT VALUE TO
THE STATE WHEN THE STATE PUTS IN
ONE BUCK AND GETS TWO BOOKS BACK
I CAN'T BE THAT I TAKE THAT
ABSOLUTELY --
WE DO EVERY DAY --
IT.
I LIKE I SAID I SET ASIDE LONG
TERM QUESTIONS ABOUT OF PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT --
ARMY TO BECOME AN ISSUE --
IN MY NECK OF THE WOODS AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WITH REGARD TO THE
NEED TO HOUSE --
MIGRANTS --
THAT ARE BEING --
NEGLECTED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT --
THAT IT WAS A DISAPPOINTMENT
TODAY IN THE COMMUNITY THAT
THOSE WERE NOT AVAILABLE TO TAKE
WHETHER NOT TO OPEN THE
ARMOURIES --
TO NON DEPARTMENT USES YEAH SO.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT NOTE THAT.
LAST CALENDAR YEAR WE DID
PROBABLY A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND SHELTER NIGHTS AGO
ACROSS THE ARMORIES THAT WE
HOUSE THE HOMELESS AND I'M NOT
AND I'M NOT SURE WHICH SPECIFIC
ARMY YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IT DEPENDS IF THE ARMORIES BEING
USED -- WE
CAN'T.
OPEN EVERY ARMORY FOR HOMELESS
SHELTERS BECAUSE THEN IT BECOMES
A IMPACT ON OUR READINESS OUR
ABILITY TO PERFORM OUR MISSIONS
BUT WHERE WE CAN --
WE DO WE DO AND WE'RE YOU KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING CONSTANTLY OUT
WAYS TO TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
HOMELESS INITIATIVES ALSO TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR MIGRANT
AGED ESPECIALLY DOWN IN IN THE
IN YOUR AREA --
SO WE'RE ALWAYS OPEN TO THAT IF
YOU EVER HAVE A QUESTION AND
JUST GIVE US A CALL BILL WALK
YOU THROUGH THE WITHOUT KNOWING
THE SPECIFICS AYE.
CANNELLA JUSTIN SO THE FOCUS ON
MIGRANTS NOT NOT THE HOMELESS
ALTHOUGH THAT CERTAINLY
CONCERNED AS WELL BUT FROM THE
TEMPORARY NATURE HOPEFULLY --
OF OF THIS RIDE REQUIREMENT --
I THINK WAS A PART OF THE ISSUE
I WOULD JUST ASK YOU TO
INTERPRET PAN AND ARE JUST NOW
KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT QUITE OVER.
WE HAVE FOUND A COUNTY FACILITY
THAT'S NOT SO SURE THAT WILL
COME COMING BACK PLEASE --
AND I'D LIKE THE STATE TO THE
STATE'S ALREADY PUT UP SOME
SIGNIFICANT MONEY.
WHICH IS GOOD I DON'T A NEVER
COME HOME EMPTY HANDED RIGHT
RIGHT -- SO
GLORIOUS NOT COMING HOME EMPTY
HANDED ON THIS ISSUE BUT AT THE
IT OUT IN A FEW YEARS TIME IF
THERE CONTINUE TO PERSIST IN
THIS PARTICULAR PROBLEM.
OF HOPE FOR THE STATE CAN BE
SOLUTION ORIENTED BEYOND MONEY
BUT HOPEFULLY THE WITH
FACILITIES --
IF IT'S STILL NEED.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER.
I JUST LIKE TO MAKE COMMON BASED
ON WHEN YOU HAVE.
AN ARMORY IN A COMMUNITY
GENERALLY.
IF IT'S COMMITTEE AND IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS IN THE IN THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT SERVE IN THAT
IN THAT ARMORY.
OUR COMMUNITY BASED IN COMMUNITY
FOCUSED ON HELPING AT ALL
MANNERS OF AND SO I JUST GOT TO
SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW.
AS YOU.
DISSOLVE THE ABILITY YOU
DISSOLVE THE SPIRIT NERO CAM IN
GO BECAUSE IN CONCORD.
YES I WAS --
YOU KNOW.
GOING UP AS YOUNG BOY.
THAT WAS THAT ARMY WAS
COMPLETELY ENGAGED IN THE
COMMUNITY IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
FASHIONS.
AND SO YOU KNOW IT'S A HUGE LOSS
AS WELL AS WE SEE THESE GO.
THAT WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO GET
BACK THERE WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
WITH THE THE THE CALL MOSCOW IS.
THE NAME WHAT THE STATION THERE
THEY HAVE THEY HAVE SOME PROPER
THAT THEY WANNA SURPLUS LEAD WE
SEE THAT AS POTENTIALLY VERY
FAVORABLE FOR US WE HAVE --
WE CAN RECRUIT THERE --
WE HAVE A LOT OF INFRASTRUCTURE
IN UNITS ALREADY THERE AND IT'S
DEFINITELY ON THE ON OUR WATCH
LIST TO TO DO SOMETHING THERE
[inaudible]
SIR.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU --
WHY DON'T WE GO ON TO USE
CHALLENGE OKAY?
SO WE'RE EXTRA NEARLY PROUD OF
THIS PROGRAM IT LIKE TO TELL
PEOPLE THIS IS A SHINING EXAMPLE
OF THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT DOES
RIGHT WE DO A LOT OF THINGS
RIGHT -- FOR
FOLKS THAT ARE NEW TO THE
COMMITTEE OUR YOUTH CHALLENGE
PROGRAM WE HAVE --
A THREE ACADEMIES THIS ONE IN
THE LOS ARE SAN LUIS OBISPO AND
THEN ONE IN STOCKTON --
THEY'RE FUNDED BY A SEVENTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE SPLIT 75% FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT 25% STATE GOVERNMENT
WITH THESE PROGRAMS ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY IS TWENTY TWO WEEK
RESIDENTIAL MILITARY STYLE.
OF SCHOOLS THAT.
SEEK TO REALLY EMPOWER --
KIDS THAT HAVE CHALLENGES EITHER
ACADEMICALLY OR SOCIALLY THESE
ARE FUNDAMENTALLY LAST CHANCE
SCHOOLS.
AND WE BRING THEM IN LIKE I SAID
BEFORE THE MILITARY TYPE
ENVIRONMENT WE TAKE A VERY
HOLISTIC APPROACH WE LOOK AT
ACADEMICS WITH LOOK AT PHYSICAL
FITNESS WE ALSO LOOK AT AT
ACADEMICS PHYSICAL FITNESS WE
LOOK AT AND A VARIETY OF THINGS.
TO TO TRY TO PROVIDE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH --
TO DELIVERING VALUE FOR THE
STUDENTS --
LAST YEAR --
WE GRADUATED ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NINE STUDENTS FROM ALL
THREE PROGRAMS WE HAD ABOUT 87%
RETENTION RATE.
AND WE CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR WAYS
TO BUILD OUT AND GROW THIS
PROGRAM.
I THINK WE'RE ONE OF THE VERY
FEW STATES THAT HAS THREE
PROGRAMS ARE THE MOST HOW ONE
VERY FEW HAVE TO WE HAVE.
THREE AND THAT WE'RE VERY VERY
PROUD OF IT I THINK WE HAVE --
OF DELIVER A LOT OF VALUE TO THE
STATE.
MULTI QUESTIONS.
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THERE ARE
[inaudible]
OF SO WHAT.
DO YOU THINK THAT THERE IS A
NEED OR DESIRE TO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM IS THIS PROS WILEY
OVERSUBSCRIBED MA'AM WITH.
IT'S A SHAME WE THE THE KIDS WE
HAVE TO TURN AWAY.
ABSOLUTELY AT IT DOES SOUND LIKE
IT -- GREAT
PROGRAM AND THEN IS IT TOO EARLY
TO KNOW WHETHER --
THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY HAS HAVING WITH HIRING
COUNSELORS.
I BELIEVE IT HAS.
THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
ENTER IS ONE OF THE FOLLOW UP.
AS YOU MENTION THAT THE PROGRAMS
ARE WIDELY OVERSUBSCRIBED ANSWER
WHAT YOU WANT.
WELL WE'D LIKE ANOTHER PROGRAM
RIGHT BUT THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HAS TO APPROVE SO I'M NOT
IN A POSITION TODAY TO ADVOCATE
FOR THAT ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
I THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT IT
FROM --
STANDPOINT OF OF OF DEMAND IN
THERE'S A DEMAND THERE FOR AND
THE CHALLENGES YOU KNOW WHERE
YOU PUT IT --
AND WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO PARTNER WITH WHOEVER
WANTS TO HELP US DO THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU CAN SHARE TECHNICAL ADVICE
IN THE SUBJECT ABSOLUTELY AND
WILL BE.
PEOPLE WHO.
GREAT HAVE A FOLLOW UP
CONVERSATION WITH YOU
ELICITATION WHEN WE CAN WE CAN --
UNDERSTAND THE OUTCOMES OF
ABSOLUTE PROGRAM DOES PROVIDE
ONE PER SHARE SPORTS SIR THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT NO MORE QUESTIONS THEN
WE WILL GO ON TO OUR LAST
SUBJECT OKAY EVASIONS I KNOW YOU
COVERED A LITTLE BIT IN YOUR
OPENING BUT MAYBE WE CAN HERE'S
MORE DETAILS.
SO.
AS I WAS AS AN EXTRA NO NO AT
THE ACTIVATIONS --
ACTIVISTS I'M SORRY YEAH I
MENTIONED IT IN SOME LEVEL OF
DETAIL IN MY OPENING COMMENTS
NOT A WHOLE LOT TO SHARE BEYOND
THAT -- IT'S
INTERESTING TODAY OUT MY AND MY
BOSS IS NOT HERE TODAY'S
ACTUALLY AMMAN JORDAN A HE'S
VISITING OUR CAVALRY SQUADRON
WHO IS CURRENTLY IN JORDAN.
ON THERE WITH THE CALL THE
JORDAN TRAIN AND EQUIP MISSION --
STILL BE MEETING THE SPOKESMAN
RETURNING YOUR LATER IN THE WEEK.
BUT I THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT
NOTICE IS THAT THESE DEPLOYMENTS
THESE ACTIVATIONS DESCRIPTION
SEE DEPLOYMENTS --
ARE NOT WINNING --
WE CONTINUE TO BE FULLY
INVESTING GAUGE TO ACROSS --
EVERY MAJOR
THEATER IN THE
EUROPEAN.
THEATER WITH THE DETERRENT
SUPPRESSION AGGRESSION OR WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN UKRAINE TRYING TO
HELP THEM.
UP -- TO THE
CENTRAL COMMAND BUT WE HAVE --
THE MAJORITY OF OUR FORCES AND
WE ALSO DO --
THEY ARE CALLED TO DO THAT WORK
SO WELL WALL THE DEPLOYMENT
CYCLES AND PARTICIPATION
EMERGENCIES CATASTROPHIC
EMERGENCIES LIKE THE ONES --
THIS FALL --
IT'S IT'S WHAT MY FOLKS DO SO.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO DO IT AT
FIFTEEN OF OBVIOUSLY THE
INTENSITY OF THESE WILD FIRES IS
INCREASING DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH OF
PERSONNEL.
TO AT TO MEET THE DEMAND WE DO.
WE DO AND WHAT WE ARE CONTINUE.
FOR WAYS TO INNOVATE --
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF MANPOWER
AND NOVEMBER WITH THE WILL OF
THE FIRE AND AND PARADISE AT THE
SAME.
TIME AND AND CERTAINLY --
IT WAS A BIG RELIEF TO HAVE YOU
AVAILABLE SPAM.
AND I THINK IT'S A SUPPORT YOU
KNOW TO BEFORE MOVE OFF THAT
SUBJECT IS THAT IF WE RUN INTO A
SITUATION WHERE.
OUR CAPACITY IS TAPPED OUT.
WE HAVE THE FIFTY THREE OTHER
STATES TERRITORIES THE DISTRICT
OF COLUMBIA FROM WHICH WE CAN
ASK AND WHEN THEY WILL DELIVER.
SO IT'S WE WILL NOT BE SHORT.
I'M DISTRICT WHERE DID YOU HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS ON FEDERAL BORDER
DEPLOYMENT AYE AYE WOOD ACTUALLY
AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE ABOUT THE
CURRENT STATUS OF OUR OPERATIONS
ON THE BORDER CERTAINLY SO.
THE OF THE CURRENT STATUS ARE
OPERATIONS RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN
PARTICIPATING ON THE BORDER.
THEY ARE DOING SOLELY --
COUNTER NARCOTICS OPERATIONS SO
MAJORITY OF THEM DO YOU
INTELLIGENCE --
WORK WITH THE OFFICE OF
INTELLIGENCE WE HAVE MANY MANY
SOLDIERS WORKING SECONDARY
VEHICLE CHECKPOINTS.
ON AND SPORTY OPS FIELD
OPERATIONS THE PORTS OF ENTRY
ACROSS THE CALIFORNIA MEXICO
BORDER -- WE
ALSO HAVE SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN
THAT MAN --
COME ACROSS THE TERRESTRIAL
BORDER AND NOT THE PORTS OF
ENTRY.
HOW MANY PERSONNEL DO WE HAVE
THEIR?
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT AND
HAS THE MISSION ITSELF CHANGED
ALL BETWEEN THE CHANGE IN
ADMINISTRATIONS.
NO -- THE
EITHER MORE OR LESS IT'S THE IS
IT HASN'T CHANGED AT ALL OKAY --
AND THAT IS IT THIS THEIR ROLE
IS DISTINGUISHABLE FROM WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
IT'S PERSONAL IS DOING ITS
ABSOLUTELY DISTINGUISHABLE.
AND WE WENT AND MADE GREAT
STRIDES TO ENSURE THAT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY DISTINGUISHABLE.
THERE ANY INCIDENTS OF USE OF
FORCE BY ANY OF OUR PERSONNEL
KNOWN AS WORK NONE --
AND WHAT'S THE COST OF THIS AT
THIS POINT --
I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER OF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD BUT I'LL GET IT
TO YOU.
MILLIONS OF ABSOLUTELY AS A
REIMBURSABLE.
IT'S SERVE IT IS WELL THERE AND
SO IT'S IMPORTANT STAND THESE
THIS THE SOLDIERS AIRMEN THAT
ARE ON THE BORDER THERE UNDER
WHAT THEY CALL TITLE THIRTY TWO
AUTHORITIES SO.
THAT MONEY FLOWS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT INTO THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT DOESN'T
TOUCH THE STATE AT ALL OKAY.
SO IN FACT IT'S NOT REIMBURSABLE
PER SE THE CHALLENGE I THINK
WHERE WE TALK ABOUT REIMBURSABLE
SIN AND THIS IS.
I THINK IT FOR A LOT OF FOLKS
DON'T KNOW IS THIS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE IS NOT
BEING REIMBURSED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
FOR ANY OF THIS --
WHICH I FIND.
EXTRAORDINARY.
SO BUT TO ST ME IT ME --
TO WITH REGARDS TO OUR PERSONNEL
WHO ARE THERE THERE'D BE THE THE
IT'S NOT REIMBURSABLE BECAUSE
IT'S BEING PAID DIRECTLY BY THE
FEDERAL AYE THAT'S CORRECT
THERE'S NO DIRECT COST OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
NAY ON WHATEVER WE WOULD --
IN THE FUTURE IF THERE'S NO NONE.
THANK YOU YOU BET [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY UNIFORMED CBP OFFICERS
BACK IN THE FIELD --
BY OUR PRESENCE THERE --
TO DATE.
WE'VE ASSISTED OR PARTICIPATED
IN THE SEIZURE OF MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
OF DRUGS METHAMPHETAMINE FAN AND
ALL OPIOIDS MARIJUANA --
THAT CAME THROUGH THE PORTS OF
ENTRY OUR SOLDIERS AIRMEN MANDY
AT SECONDARY VEHICLE CHECKPOINTS.
GOOD JOB THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT AND AND WE WEREN'T GOING
TO SKIP THE DISCUSSION BUT MAYBE
SENT TO BROUGHT IT UP ON THE
TRANS GENDER.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR FOLKS
TO UNDERSTAND --
CAN WEAR OUT WHERE WE'RE GOING.
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES THE
NATIONAL GUARD SHOW.
WE'RE COMPELLED BY STATUTE TO
FOLLOW THE RULES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RELATIVE TO FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
GUARD SO WE HAVE TO FOLLOW THOSE
RULES.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU'RE A IF YOU'RE
HOWEVER THE GENDER IDENTIFY IT
DOESN'T MATTER TO US WE DON'T
ASK WE DON'T CARE AS LONG AS YOU
CAN FIGHT WE DON'T CARE.
WHAT YOU AYE GENDER IDENTIFY
ASSET -- AND
WE TAKEN FOLKS IN.
IN WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY THERE
ARE AND WE WE SIMPLY DON'T CARE --
I BELIEVE THAT THAT --
THAT THE BANWILL BE LIFTED
AGAIN I I HAVE A HARD TIME
BELIEVING IT WILL BE AND I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS
THAT.
IF YOU'RE TRANSGENDER YOU'RE
ALREADY IN THE MILITARY
REGARDLESS OF YOUR COMPONENT THE
THE THE THE LAW OR THAT THE
COURT.
THE AT THE COURT ORDERED.
DOES NOT.
BOUNCE YOU OUT YOU CAN STAY IF
YOU'RE THE GOING THROUGH GENDER
REASSIGNMENT SURGERY YOU CAN DO
THAT AS WELL CURRENTLY --
NOBODY'S NOBODY'S GONNA KICK YOU
OUT THESE THEY FUNDAMENTALLY
WHAT IT DID WAS CLOSE THE FRONT
DOOR -- THEN
I I WHICH ONE TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY WAS WHERE THE YEAH I
WAS AND THE REASON I SAID WE
WERE GOING TO SKIP IT IS BECAUSE
WE HAD THE QUESTION THERE BUT
THERE IS THERE'S WHAT WE'RE
WAITING FOR ONE MORE COURT CASE
WAS -- SET
THAT UP CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT BACKGROUND SURE.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER.
THAT IS SO THAT WAS A GREAT
DANCER AND I YOU KNOW IT IS A
MEMBER THOSE TWO COMMUNITY MIGHT
IMAGINETHERE'S A TIME IN MY
LIFE I NEVER THOUGHT SOMEONE WAY
WHAT YOU'RE WEARING WOULD SAY
SOMETHING.
ALONG THE LINES OF WHAT YOU JUST
SAID -- AND
SO I'M APPRECIATIVE --
OF CLEAVE IMMERSE YOURSELF IN
THIS EVEN THE TERMINOLOGY I
STRUGGLE WITH IT SO --
HATS OFF TO YOU FOR FORGET ON IS.
THE THE THE LACK OF OF DATA
THOUGH IT COULD BE A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED I RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S
COMING FROM A POSITIVE PLACE A
LOOK WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO
DIFFERENTIATE.
BUT MáS ALWAYS CURIOUS TO KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE IMPACTED BY
SOMETHING --
I DON'T I IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU MAY
NOT KNOW WHAT THAT NUMBER IS THE
ONLY WE BUT IT IN THE DAY WHICH
WERE NOT COMPELLED TO MEASURE IT
WE DON'T.
AND WE CAN MEASURE THEM IN OTHER
WAYS AND THEN HE MENTIONED
UNDERSTANDING THAT NO ONE'S
BEING KICKED OUT --
BUT IT IS IN IT'S HARD TO
QUANTIFY THOSE WHO CHOOSE NOT TO
TO TO IN LAST.
HOW MANY FOLKS HAVE BEEN TURNED
AWAY THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF IT
THIS NONE THAT I'M AWARE OF NONE
THE AWARE --
IN THAT WOULD JUST BE WHAT'S
UNDER YOUR PURVIEW RIGHT RIGHT
EXACTLY YEAH.
OKAY LATELY --
THANK YOU.
SIR ARE ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY
MORE QUESTIONS.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
WAS --
INFORMATIVE AND APPRECIATE ALL
THE MEMBERS THAT STUCK IT OUT
TILL THE END.
AND WITH THAT WE ARE TURN